start with obviously the nice and easy
stuff and being that you guys at the end
of season three washed up in America
this is obviously an allegory for
immigration policy in the West what can
we expect what can fans expect let's
start with that one after you washed up
on shore x' in america what can fans
expect from season four wow what can
they expect well you know i think this
is you know the great thing about this
season is it is the story of this
immigrant family and you know Jamie and
Claire finally are in this position to
build a new life for themselves from
scratch and you know leave behind all of
the trouble that Jamie had in Scotland
and you know it's not that America is
not without its complications for them
but we've never really seen them both
sort of have this fresh start and so
it's a different dynamic for the
characters obviously we will see lots of
new characters come in as well there's
some of Jamie's family we are currently
in an touch Acosta's house at the moment
but yeah it's it's you know it's a
really it's a really different season
and it's it's really interesting it's
kind of like there's a you know if a
band has a real success at the beginning
and in the world of music fans come back
and they want what attracted them to
that band in the beginning but they also
want to move forward and as an artist
I'm sure you want to move forward so
it's probably really exciting for you
that you do get your characters are
getting a new start but you got a bit of
a new start as well yeah I mean you know
Claire this season is in such a
different place I guess then we've then
we've seen her before I mean obviously
you know she's had such an emotional
connection to America anyway because she
raised her daughter there so there's
this sense of being closer to Brianna
just because they're on the same land I
suppose but there's a lot of
complications being in America in this
time in the 18th century because Claire
knows sort of the history or the general
history of what's happening in
around her and she can see what's
happening around her and that's very
hard for a modern woman to to observe
and you know in some ways their lives
become entwined in some of the
situations that are going on at that
time and that's very difficult for her
but as the season progresses and they
they sort of start their own life in in
their own place it's a chance for them
to sort of create their own environment
and and build from the ground up their
family and their little society and
community that they that they want to
have so that's quite nice to see it's an
unusual situation I suppose for a
daughter to see her mother in one way in
a relationship
Claire's relationship with Frank as
opposed to the relationship she knows
and sees how her mother is when she
speaks about about Jamie how do you
think you know how do you think she will
or is her character is dealing with that
kind of juxtaposition God as a woman
isn't she with both men so yeah I mean I
you know I think Claire in the beginning
of season 3 when we really saw her in
the 40s 50s and 60s with Frank you know
even though she was very accomplished
she was a very in many ways her life was
compromised you know she had put this
huge part of herself to one side and I
think someone who's living without
intimacy and without that kind of
romantic love you know it she definitely
closed off a side of herself and she was
very reserved and I think Breanna would
be quite surprised by how free and wild
in many ways Claire is you know and I
don't know how she feels about seeing
that side of her mother and think does
anyone want to know that you know I'm
gross but you know I definitely think in
the beginning of this season as well the
look you know not being with Breanna or
not being able to know how Breanna is is
is something that weighs quite heavily
on Claire fans are who know the book
obviously we'll be anticipating
meeting between Brianna and Jamie mm-hmm
how do you think I mean everybody that
is obviously going to be a huge part of
season four yeah I say obviously I
talked to me about what leading up to
that is like and the anticipation for
that both you know inside the production
and outside you know we haven't filmed
it yeah yeah so you know I guess
obviously that's going to be such a huge
moment you know just to have this family
unit together in this configuration is
going to be huge you know I I think it
will be complicated yeah because we
don't do anything in very simply but
yeah I also think there's going to be a
lot of healing and I think that that's
that's probably the biggest thing is
probably there'll be a lot of healing
from everybody being able to sort of be
able to speak their truth and see each
other and that'll be beautiful to watch
what's what was the big surprise what is
the biggest surprise for you now I think
I probably asked you that when we were
on set a couple of years ago when you
were just getting into filming season
three
this show is obviously grown for you
changed your life in many ways
what'swhat's continues to be maybe the
biggest surprise for you about this
project you know it's it's just been
such a wild ride to be on something that
you know obviously there the the book
series had such a huge fan base and a
huge life and that had sustained itself
for over 20 years so coming on to the
show you never know if that's gonna work
you know if people are gonna like what
you do or not that's that's a quite a
risk but it's been it's been amazing I
mean it's been so gratifying to be part
of something that's so much bigger than
the nos and you see that people's lives
are so invested in these characters and
you know there's generations of a family
who are
to it and that's you know that's crazy
like to I you know I was a big fan of
Lord of the Rings and stuff like that
when I was growing up and you know just
to be part of something I mean obviously
we're not on that level but part of
something that's in people's lives and
that they bond over yeah it's just it's
very cool the fans are I mean and
sometimes you can use the word fan is
used incorrectly because it's obviously
an abbreviation of fanatic but there are
people who are fanatical about the books
and about the show you got engaged
recently congratulations by the way
and have you did were you aware that
maybe some people might be a bit at a
joint about the fact that well you and
Sam didn't end up what you have a life
outside of this world I mean there are
some people who are you know heavily
invested in the show and the people
involved right and that's lovely you
know I I would say 99.9% of the things
that I have seen have just been so
positive and lovely and and you know
it's just so nice that people are so
happy for you and they send all their
well wishes and the very small
percentage of people who don't want to
be happy for other people you know
that's just a part of everything so you
just have to forget about that and well
you know it's it's this is another it's
one of the other things that this show
has brought me you know I probably
wouldn't have met my partner if it
hadn't been for this show so that's been
a great thing so thank you Islander
understands that world as well okay we
have a steam enos rating back home and
obviously the show's been going on for a
while now on a and I have it's right
here on the cue cards very serious
drivers the question coming here how
would you rate the steam enos for season
four on a scale of one to ten one being
not steamy ten being too hot to handle
well it's definitely not too hot because
we've been there and it's in Scott
you're shooting in Scotland you know I
think seven seven oh yeah that's social
family can still enjoy it together yeah